la région à prendre plusieurs types de
mesures sur plusieurs niveaux
la région est un acteur de cette vaste
chaîne de responsabilités qui doit se
mettre en place dans notre pays
aujourd'hui
vu l'enjeu sanitaire et les conséquences
et humaines et économiques
donc premier niveau effectivement vous
venez de parler des écoles les lycées
donc bien sûr les transports scolaires
seront suspendus
puisqu'il n'y aura plus d'élèves à
transporter mais les transporteurs
feront l'objet d'indemnisations
forcément et cela va s'inscrire dans
l'ensemble des mesures économiques que
nous allons mettre en place pour
accompagner les employeurs les pme les
tpe qui sont aujourd'hui complètement
ravagé 1 de façon instantanée par cette
crise et par le ralentissement
d'activité alors sur les lycées par
ailleurs nos agents des lycées seront
maintenus dans les lycées parce que il
va y avoir des professeurs qui vont
continuer à venir pour assurer
l'enseignement numérique et donc les
agents seront là pour l'entretien des
lycées pour la restauration
nous allons faire en sorte aux côtés des
rectorats dans une chaîne de coopération
bien bien sentis pour que vraiment on se
serre les coudes tous et qu'on soit en
confiance les uns les autres nous allons
faire en sorte que la continuité
pédagogique soit garanti c'est à dire
qu'il n'y ait pas de rupture et que des
familles qui n'auraient pas de
d'équipements informatiques puissent en
avoir dans sa nouvelle roue grain il ya
aussi le sujet de la connexion parce
qu'il ya des personnes qui habitent dans
des endroits alors surtout en milieu
rural mais ça peut aussi être en milieu
urbain ou la connexion des pas bonnes
donc là nous allons mettre en place
toute une série de dispositions d'une
part voir si peut-être pour les élèves
concernés pourraient pas y avoir un
autre lieu que leur lieu d'habitation
qui pourraient les accueillir
tiers lieux et puis nous allons aussi
peut-être par le biais d'une technologie
particulière que nous maîtrisons à la
région et qui permet d'amener de la delà
du très haut débit dans des zones qui en
sont dépourvus bien mettre cela en place
ça s'appelle air cube enfin je veux pas
rentrer dans des détails techniques mais
en tout cas continuité pédagogique
opération complète avec les acteurs
académiques avec les deux recteurs pour
que véritablement tout le monde se sente
en confiance et j'en profite pour dire
que dans cette ce contexte c'est cette
crise dans laquelle nous sommes
je pense que le maître mot c'est
véritablement la confiance et moi je
suis là pour vous dire que la région aux
côtés de tous les acteurs aux côtés des
parents aux côtés des agents de la
région qui sont forcément très impacté
aux côtés des entreprises aux côtés des
associations la région fera tout son
possible pour atténuer pour les
conséquences pour accompagner pour
mettre les moyens à disposition
il faut vraiment qu'on se sente en
confiance et le premier acte de
confiance c'est une coopération totale
avec l'état elle se traduira lundi par
une première réunion de crise qui sera
copiloté état région en direction du
monde économique mais avant de parler du
monde économique je voudrais aussi parlé
des agents de la région qui sont des
habitants un pacte --l'un et qui donc
vont avoir comme tout un chacun à régler
le problème entre le travail et puis les
gardes d'enfants
donc on va développer un le plus
possible télétravail pour les personnes
qui ont des problèmes de garde d'enfants
pour les personnes aussi qu'ils sont
peut-être potentiellement fragile donc
le télétravail très très développé et
puis
je voudrais aussi ajouter que sur le
plan de la région nous allons veiller
face à la réduction d'effectifs que nous
allons avoir puisque forcément nous
allons avoir une réduction d'effectifs
nous allons prioriser les actions qui
elles ne doivent pas s'arrêter et les
actions qu'ils ne doivent pas s'arrêter
pour nous c'est d'abord les paiements
les paiements des salaires bien entendu
des agents et puis les paiements aux
entreprises aux entreprises et à tous
les acteurs notamment aussi associative
culturelle sportif les paiements pour ne
pas rajouter de la crise à la crise et
enfin enfin nous mettons en place et
nous y réfléchissons donc c'est en train
d'être formalisé je veux pas trop
rentrer dans les détails des mesures d'
aide économique pour accompagner les
entreprises et des mesures que nous sur
lesquels nous délibérerons entre élus et
qui vont permettre de mobiliser 80
millions au bénéfice des entreprises
pour faciliter leur trésorerie à travers
des mesures de garantie des mesures de
prêts des mesures de différé de
remboursement qui sont à la main de la
région en lien avec des pays et avec les
banques parce que ce sont les banques
qui sont en front office ainsi pu dire
de cette crise de trésorerie qui ça va
de façon dramatique sur les entreprises
et je pense spécialement en nous avons
nos entreprises industrielles qui sont
gênés dans leur approvisionnement et
nous avons toutes les entreprises du
secteur tertiaire
l'entreprise de services qui du jour au
lendemain voix voient leur activité
dégringolé de façon absolument
dramatiques que ce soit les entreprises
de l'événementiel du tourisme de la
restauration les traiteurs nous sommes à
leurs côtés
nous serons attentifs à à leur demande à
leur suggestion est vraiment dans une
coopération fortement senti région et à
acteurs économiques nous construirons la
chaîne qui est nécessaire